let's get into this week's mailbag email
info davidpackman.com if you have a
question comment criticism suggestion
whatever you also may be featured if you
leave a YouTube comment or if you uh
send us a message on Twitter or Facebook
or whatever the case may be
uh let's get right into it because there
are so many interesting messages I want
to start with a negative message yeah
sometimes we start with something
negative and then we move on to positive
things clay wrote in with a very
aggressive message clay said Gutfeld
kicks every late night fascist ass
maggots to ass that's why you whine
about them I can't remember the last
time I mentioned Greg Gutfeld you whine
about vaccines because your dumb asses
ran to pump the clot shot you now you
clowns see that it's killing people and
always the Perpetual victim it's not
funny
but at the same time you're all such
narcissistic lobotomized morons you
won't admit your party leaders F to you
because Liberals are idiots now run off
and wait for the impending abortion hmm
I guess I do support
self-aborting liberals this is a sick
person
um I feel so bad for people like this
because their lives must just be
terrible that they talk like this that
they're willing to even
send messages to people like this one
was by Facebook you know it's like you
this we can see this guy's full name and
where he works and I would even if I
thought stuff like this which I don't
I would be
embarrassed into a hole in the ground
if I ever sent someone a message like
this and so I feel bad for these people
I really do it's more of a sad thing
that they are willing to send messages
like this than anything else but they
exist and there are many many many of
them one more criticism this one came
via email from Wayne Wayne said are you
getting your content from MSNBC CNN
you're an idiot y-o-u-r
it's almost a requirement folks if you
send hate mail you have to have the
wrong your your an idiot my an idiot
you're an idiot if you believe any of
this just wait for the speech tonight
not this was about the State of the
Union not one word will be the truth is
the Biden crime family continues to lie
about everything gullible low IQ people
like you is the reason they're slowly
wrong there and then it should be r
instead of is slowly letting socialism
take over our country wake up idiots you
know it's this is this isn't about
bringing being a grammar Nazi it's if
you're accusing me and my audience of
being low IQ and stupid and all these
things
you've got half a dozen grammar errors
in a four-line email and you want to
call me low IQ come on guys and again
it's more of a tragedy it's an
educational tragedy but understand
something is correlating here as I've
said before
if people learn media literacy and
critical thinking early
it's like a vaccine against
disinformation
and it's not a shock that some of the
people who have six errors in a
four-line email
also believe things that aren't true
about everything from vaccines to
socialism to whatever the case may be uh
it is it is not a surprise it's not
being a grammar Nazi it's noticing
there are Trends here all right Bjorn
wrote in about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
response to the state of the union says
hey David thanks for the show I listened
to your show February 8th saying that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders response was
maybe the most vile State of the Union
response you heard to me it wasn't even
a response to the State of the Union as
it didn't really address anything in the
State of the Union it felt like a
pre-recorded Biden is woke and bad and
the left is horrible statement vile yes
a response I don't know what do you
think you know one of the things that
Bjorn is right about and I realized
after the fact
I don't I'd have to listen to it again
I don't know that Sarah Huckabee Sanders
needed to wait until after the speech to
give that speech what what I mean is
she could have recorded the speech
before Biden State of the Union Address
and it would have been just as relevant
Irrelevant in reality because I think
Bjorn is right I don't know that
anything Biden actually said was
addressed yes socialism and woke and all
these different things but I don't think
that the actual subject matter of
Biden's speech was addressed by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I think Bjorn is
absolutely on to something it really
wasn't an actual response Matt Rhoden
and said David sir I love the new
backdrop on the set you're the best Matt
you know I have to tell you
um
on this program
anytime we've changed anything
if we're lucky half the audience is
positive about it when we change music
we get so many criticisms when we've
changed set elements we get criticisms
when I went to oh you know now I do wear
a tie on the show now I'm no longer
wearing a tie now I'm not even wearing
the the Blazer I'm back this it's always
negative Our Guest hosts negative of
which we'll get to by the way this
change to the backdrop which I believe
is a beautiful change has been received
more positively than anything we have
ever changed on the show which is great
makes me happy you love to see it and
we've got a couple other small changes
up Our Sleeve which will be coming soon
Mickel wrote to me and said David
there's something that bugs me when you
cover George Santos in your show you
keep referring to him as George Anthony
devolder kitara Santos I think you
should not include Katara at this point
what he did in his past as a drag I
think he I think Michael means as a drag
queen was not a lie and he doesn't know
any explanation about it to anybody I
know you're not asking for that but when
you keep including that part when
covering his continuous lies you make it
look like that's a lie too it wouldn't
be a big deal unless homophobes
transphobes and drag phobes could use
that against him which I'm afraid can
happen that's why I think you should
limit his name to George Anthony
devolder Santos already long enough
without Katara so I have two thoughts
about this number one Katara is related
to a lie because he said it wasn't him
initially when the photos came out of
Santos and drag which is politically
relevant because Republicans have been
on a crusade against drag queens and
drag shows and drag time reading hour
whatever
um he lied and said that wasn't me and
then later said actually it was me so it
is part of the lie that being said I've
received emails on both sides of this I
received a few emails like what Michael
says which is it could be sort of seen
as like mildly homophobic or drag phobic
or whatever to include Katara in the
name because that was his drag name and
others who wrote to me including people
from the LGBT community who said David
he lied about the drag stuff it's
completely fair to include Katara when
you say George Anthony Katara devolder
Santos sort of like Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benell II
I have stopped using Katara over the
last week
I don't have a strong feeling one way or
the other
but certainly nothing homophobic is
meant by it
John wrote in and said if Trump is still
president why does it matter that the
election was stolen seems like it
wouldn't matter right great job David
and Luke keep it up that's from John who
also goes by Mongoose yeah this is one
of those you know
the January 6th riots were actually
totally peaceful and the rioters were
antifa and it's like wait but so were
they peaceful or were they antifa
um it is true it is true that for the
people who say the election was stolen
and also I believe Trump is still the
president if Trump is still the
president it wasn't really stolen was it
if you believe Trump won good luck
speaking to these people I mean it's
like you're trying to apply logic to
claims that are completely illogical
so while you're completely correct I
believe it would be a waste of time to
try to confront these folks with that
but probably entertaining on some level
Daniel wrote in about my Replacements my
guest hosts and said David none of these
people comes even close to you I cannot
watch the show if you're not there
please don't go away again says Daniel
well Daniel I'm sorry to tell you I'm
going to continue going away breaks are
important vacations are important now
we've gone over this issue with the
guest hosts many time with you in the
audience there was a time when when I
was off there was no show just there
were no shows and a lot of people didn't
like that they said David you should
have someone fill in for you
we started having people fill in which
by the way is a lot more work for us
um and no matter who fills in
I get a ton of emails saying I didn't
like that person people write in they
say I don't like when Luke Beasley fills
in I prefer farron we have Farren people
write in farron's terrible you should
have uh you know Jesse dollar more or
someone else Jesse dollar more fills in
for me Jessie's terrible he yells too
much someone said you should have Luke
do it there is not going to be a perfect
fit but I think there's a couple
takeaways from this number one it is
flattering that me being gone is
upsetting to people in the sense that
there are people that are sort of
counting on the show and like the show
enough that when I'm not here it's
upsetting to them I I find that
beautiful I think that that's a
testament to the community that we've
built here and it's a really great thing
now where it get cycle is the people who
threaten to cancel their memberships if
I have replacement hosts or go on
vacation you know
if you're telling me you value the show
so much that you want me to be here more
and you're willing to pay for a
membership it seems a little strange
that you would say I'm going to stop
watching and cancel my subscription if
you take any vacations it seems not only
insensitive to the reality that like hey
I need breaks too
but if you love the show so much that
you're Furious when I'm gone why would
you swear it off and start supporting
the show that's a little bit of a bummer
but here's the bottom line nobody likes
not everybody likes any of the hosts
that we have okay and after all it is
the David packman show so it sort of
makes sense that at least in general
you're tuning in to see me
so I'm very sensitive to that we are
going to continue a rotating cast of
guest hosts that way there will be
hopefully someone everybody likes and if
you only want to see me then just don't
watch or listen on the days that I'm
gone I think that's the best solution
for everybody and most importantly I
really appreciate everybody who does
have a paid subscription and when we're
off writes in and says hey David just
wanted to let you know I'm a paid
supporter you being gone reminded me how
much I I like the show and count on it
enjoy the time away can't wait to see
you when you're back those are really
beautiful messages I get like three
whenever I'm away okay uh we have a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com we'll see you then